when we think about how the executive or
the legislative branch have some form of
check or power over the judicial branch
a key element of that is the executives
ability to appoint judges to federal
courts including the US Supreme Court
but it's not just that the president can
decide who gets to be a justice they
have to be confirmed by the Senate and
what you see over here what I'm about to
play are the confirmation hearings from
Justice Sonia Sotomayor in 2009 and what
I hope you get from it is it's not an
easy process this is going to be a
question from Senator Chuck Grassley
who's Republican from Iowa and you're
going to be asking about whether
marriage is a state or a federal
question so do you agree that marriage
is a question reserved for the states to
decide based on Baker versus Nelson that
also question that's pending an
impending in many courts as you know the
issue of marriage and what constitutes
it is a subject of much public
discussion and there's a number of cases
in state courts addressing the issue of
what who regulates it under what terms
can I please interrupt you I thought I
was asking a very simple question based
upon a precedent that Baker versus
Nelson is based on the proposition that
yesterday in so many cases whether it
was Griswold whether roe v wade whether
it was Chevron whether it's a whole
bunch of other cases that you made
reference to the Casey case the Gonzalez
case the Leegin creative leather
products case the Kahlo case the you
made that case to me you said these are
precedents now are you saying to me that
Baker versus Nelson is not a precedent
no sir I just haven't reviewed Baker in
a while and so I actually don't know
what the status
is if it is the courts precedent as I've
indicated in all of my answers I will
apply that precedent to the facts of any
new situation that implicates it always
the first question then tell me tell me
what sort of a process you might go
through so anyway you can see that this
is not an easy process and in this
situation you have an appointment by a
Democratic president and you have
questions from a Republican senator and
this is fairly typical there they're
likely to ask more pointed questions and
try to get the appointee to trip up and
if you were to see questions from a
Democratic senator they'd be more likely
to ask questions that would make the
nominee look a little bit better and
that tends to always be the case if it's
from the same party they tend to try to
smooth the process while the opposition
party tries to make it a little bit more
difficult and an interesting thing to
think about is justice Sotomayor
eventually does get appointed to the
Supreme Court but what was the goal of
Senator Grassley here and asking these
questions even if he knew that she was
eventually going to be appointed there's
other themes that we've talked about in
government that he might be playing - he
might be asking these questions more for
his constituents or there might be an
element of even if a Supreme Court
justice is going to be appointed at the
end of the day there's also the court of
public opinion so to speak and these
might be opportunities to sow some seeds
of doubt or to make it a little bit more
difficult for a Supreme Court justice to
in the future vote one way or another
based on what they say during these
hearings interesting things to talk
about